foreign
let's go out to Atlanta Georgia home of
the second place behind the Astros
Braves what's up Brian
hey John how are you thank you for
taking my call you got it what's up
brother
got a two-part question I'm hoping you
can help me with Let's Do It um am I
wrong for asking my wife to go to
counseling with me and if not
how do I encourage her that we need it
and the back story to it is uh this is
my second marriage been married almost
four years
um have three teenage boys and then a
two-year-old daughter
um about eight months ago started
noticing a change and knew something was
off and then back in January
um discovered she was talking to an ex
for about
six seven eight months
um said it was nothing physical don't
think it was after uh doing any some
investigating and uh she just basically
thinks that I should forgive her Let It
Go and move on with life
have you been cheated on before
uh no
okay
um
to answer your first question no
if your marriage is going wonderful
if your marriage is hanging on by a
spider's web
asking the person you care about can we
go see a professional that can help us
either take this relationship to the
next level to
insulate it for things that are gonna
come because things are gonna come or to
save this thing no asking to your
partner to go see a therapist to go see
a marriage counselor is is one of the
highest forms of Honor I think
I asked my wife recently and she said ah
thank God I was about to ask you so no I
don't I think that's a uh something is
of high honor
she doesn't get a vote
into how you quote unquote feel
she doesn't get a vote as to how
um you
should respond
will she sending photos back and forth
uh yes there was photos you know she
basically said
uh you know we're good friends you know
I didn't tell you because I know you
wouldn't let me be friends with somebody
at the opposite sex
well that's just gaslighting she's just
trying to make you the bad guy here what
kind of photos
uh
uh her in a bikini
um bro Brian you know
you know
oh yeah I'm I'm not I'm not an idiot you
know I I know there was there was more
there than just friends because I don't
have a female friend that I would send
myself out in the out at the pool
pictures I know
yes you know Brian you know
right so it's one of those things where
I don't know it's uh like it was
obviously more than just friends you
know you have I'm not friends with I
mean I'm friends with my ex because we
have kids but
all our text messages are with my wife
included in a group text message that's
very very wise that's very wise just
because I don't want that situation to
come up yeah you know and and I told her
you know when we sat down and talked
about it I'm like you know
it may not have been physical but it's
still an emotional affair absolutely and
she doesn't she doesn't agree that it's
an emotional affair she's like it was
just friends I'm like if I said if you
caught me talking to another woman
behind your back sending her pictures of
me in the gym or me you wouldn't just go
oh okay y'all are just friends I am or
her sending you bikini photos or topless
photos and being like nah we're just
friends and you'd be like all right no
no right you're not crazy
um
um so I'm assuming you asked her to go
to counseling and she said no
she's a very private person
um she's gonna be private all by herself
right
because
you don't trust her
and you shouldn't
and she is not doing anything to regain
that trust other than blame you
for how you should be feeling it's not
that big a deal oh my gosh I knew you're
gonna act like this all that gaslighting
bullcrap
right and you have a two-year-old and
you've been through hell before with a
divorce you know how awful it is
and my fear for you is you're gonna
think so little of your own self-worth
you're going to shut this sucker down
and just deal with what comes
and that's that's kind of the reason
that what made me call you is there is
zero Intimacy in the in the marriage
um she blames it on the kid and you know
her body
um the one that she's sending pictures
of to her ex
right
and that's uh you know the uh and that's
that's what I've said and you know
basically she has said if I don't
let it go then I need to let her go
um obviously
bro do you hear what I mean
yeah oh no I know I'm just trying to
what what like obviously you can't just
convince somebody to go to counseling if
they're not going to go They're not
going to go Ryan she is Brian Brian she
has left your marriage
this is a common move she's trying to
make this whole thing your fault so that
you will ultimately leave
and that's that's exactly what I told my
my pastor is how I feel it's not I'm
telling you right now she is done
and she is coming up with excuse after
excuse she's withholding intimacy or not
going to a medical doctor or a therapist
to try to heal her body heal her mind
hear her soul it's not uncommon for
there to be intimacy issues with a
two-year-old in the house that's very
common but what's not common is just
throwing her hands up and blaming you
for it
right well she said she's gonna go uh to
the doctor to uh
see what's going on and behavior is a
language
and she can say everything she wants but
her behavior is telling you she ain't
going
and now she's making ultimatums and
threats if you don't if you don't
shove your feelings in a box and bury
him in the backyard
I'm out of here
and then when you can't do that because
you have too much
you have too much self-worth
and you value the picture of marriage
that your sons are seeing you value what
love and responsibility looks like for
your two-year-old she's gonna leave and
blame you
he was crazy
he wouldn't let it go
and and that's that's kind of what I've
said is like
it's not
it's not good for the kids to see this
and it's not good for our daughters see
this because this isn't what marriage is
yes you are correct
so I don't I mean is it something where
I should just be like hey
if you don't want to go to counseling we
probably need to go another Direction I
I will never be the person to tell you
to leave your wife
I don't know you well enough I don't
know her well enough unless it is a uh
an incredibly abusive situation
no it's it's not that we get along
um you know of course you do she's
getting she's got the
she's got things taken care of
right yeah she's not dumb
she's not done not at all very smart yes
if I'm in your shoes what I would do is
I would a start seeing somebody on my
own
I would go call a counselor on my own I
do I talked to uh a pat one of my former
pastors that I want you to go see a
clinical counselor
okay
uh I want you to call local counselor in
your area begin to sit down and work
through it because my guess is why did
you get divorced the first time
um
it was kind of oil and water
um the crazy thing is we get the we get
along better now as co-parents than we
did as parents yeah it's actually I hear
that with some regularity what's the
pressure of the marriage is gone people
act like adults and then they act like
grown-ups and they realize oh I don't
have to choose misery but
it's after everything's all wrapped up
um
when you say oil and water I don't
really buy that what else was there
uh there really wasn't anything else was
there anger and rage and people treating
each other bad or yeah I mean obviously
we we fought a lot and I mean nothing
physical ever but it was just always
uh
always arguing fighting
um
it just was was not a not a good
situation okay I don't want to blame
that on well I was oil and she was water
because if I was to drill down I think
me and my wife were oil and water but we
made a commitment and we figured it out
see what I'm saying right and so at the
end of the day there were some choices
made
probably my guess would be the choices
were
Brian you need to shut your mouth
and that got hard is that fair
yeah that's fair yeah and here we are
again
right and like an earlier caller you
married your unfinished business and
we're right back in the same boat
right
um have you sat down with your current
wife and asked her
um
to build a life with you
yeah and she you know she says she's
done with it she's moving forward uh she
wants us to move forward
um you know she's
she's been apologetic but it's one of
those things where it's you know it's
it's still in the back your mind you
know she says she's when we talk about
it she says she feels like I'm putting
myself on a pedestal and putting herself
you know below me because she was in the
situation not me and you know I'm like
I'm not stupid enough to know that I
couldn't have easily been in that
situation that you put yourself in
you know she said she made a mistake you
know she was at fault it should have
never happened that's all true that's
all true and good for her good for her
for owning
but she's not
she's weaponizing the apology
she's not taking full accountability
right if I do that same thing
and I tell my wife hey I really screwed
up
I put myself in a position and I
compromised our marriage I didn't go all
the way but man I screwed up screwed up
what does rebuilding trust look like now
because we got to build something new
yes that's the path forward the path
forward cannot be so you just need to
suck it up and get over and I said I was
you should just divorce me
come on man right and that and and
that's what I like she says forgiveness
means forgetting and I'm like that's not
that's not what forgiveness means I'm
like I if I was in your situation I
would I would say the same thing I would
be like hopefully you forget it
um you know but that you'll never forget
it
right there is another man holding
pictures of your wife wearing almost
nothing or nothing depending on which
ones you actually saw and that she
deleted right
of course it's going to be in your mind
well and he's married so there's a you
know there's a whole other element yeah
that's I mean that's getting into his
head and world I wouldn't even spend a
second in that world
yeah you've got enough trouble on your
own in your own house
right here's the deal you're not crazy
and when you're with a master gaslighter
you can just start to think that the sky
is actually
red and green
because they just say it so much but
you're not crazy
the question you need to get to the
bottom of does is that it is does your
wife want to be married to you or not
and marriage looks like working really
hard to regain Intimacy in the house not
just sexual but to regain connectivity
intimacy uh I mean uh being married
looks like waking up every day and
taking a knee and saying how can I love
you more
and hoping to God that you do the same
for her
right marriage looks like
um I hurt you and I'm so sorry
when you're ready
I'll do whatever it takes
not oh my gosh are you bringing this up
again you're the worst you should just
divorce me oh come on dude you know I
mean
right
so let me let me close with this I know
what I'm saying is hard
I also know that you know everything
that I'm saying
and there's something in your spirit
that does not want to confront the
reality of your marriage right now
and my guess is like I said earlier
you've been through hell with divorce
again and the thought of going through
that again is so terrible
you can avoid it at all cost even if it
just means biting your lip and getting
through it
and I can't tell you one way or the
other man I don't know what you went
through last time I don't know what that
cost you last time both psychologically
and physically and financially I don't
know
foreign
and I know that you're really really
lonely
and the person that you looked in the
eye and said before your friends and
family and God I I will forever
and she said it back
it's not coming back
so you all have to decide are we going
to build something completely new and
you need to ask her point blank is she
going to be a part of building something
new with you and if so here's what this
is going to look like
here's what you need this to look like
and then honestly you're going to ask
her what does she need this to look like
and then you'll have to move forward or
y'all gotta have some hard conversations
about what comes next
I wish you the absolute best moving
forward my brother please let me know
how those conversations go
but it's time to stop circling and
circling and circling and it's time to
Turn All the Lights On turn the music
off party's over the dance is stopped we
need to sit down at this table let all
the glitter on the floor land
and then we got to figure out what our
relationship is is going to be worth
moving forward
it's hard man but I'll be with you every
step of the way